featuring multiple cancellations a
surprising reveal and lots of propane
and propane accessories Hank Peggy and
Bobby's Journey To The King of the Hill
finale has been long and eventful King
of the Hill holds up due in no small
part to its forgiving attitude toward
the peculiarities of its characters the
show makes no bones about their
shortcomings but it always gives them
space to grow many of the characters are
based on personalities from series
Creator Mike judge's childhood giving
the whole show a sense of down-to-earth
realism that was rare in comedies of its
time jokes that would have quickly
descended into cheap shots in most other
sitcoms have a way of disarming
themselves instead over the course of
episodes the series almost always leads
with a message of acceptance though it's
also never afraid to poke fun at the
over-the-top traits of its Ensemble why
do you have to hate what you don't
understand I don't hate you Bobby Hank
Hill's family and friends friends feel
like people you might meet at the
grocery store or at a company picnic the
relationship between Peggy and Hank is
impressively committed and supportive
and any apprehension they feel about
Bobby's outlandish interests and
decisions is eventually outweighed by
their desire to let him Express himself
despite occasional slow episodes or
jokes that don't land the cleverness of
King of the Hill often lies in its
refusal to pretend to be anything but
what it is while also being more complex
than audiences might guess at first
after such a lengthy run it's perhaps
more surprising that King of the Hill
lasted as long as it did and was only
canceled in season 13. according to Mike
Judge the series was essentially
canceled in 2005 only for Fox to
surprise the crew by ordering more
episodes the episode originally intended
to close out the series was season 11's
Lucky's wedding suit which sees lucky
and Luanne get married alongside a
subplot involving a frivolous lawsuit
however the show was renewed yet again
making the episode nothing more than the
season 11 finale by the time King of the
Hill was actually canceled the show had
already faced death several times though
the abrupt end may have disappointed
viewers judge seemed to fine with it
noting that the Chicago Tribune I think
it's a good time to stop I'd rather stop
when it's still decent rather than run
it to the ground it'll be a little weird
this will be the first time since 1992
that I haven't had a show on the air but
I'm okay with it even some of the most
popular sitcoms in TV history have been
criticized for having less than
satisfying conclusions but the episode
to Sirloin with love grants fans a
fulfilling final note by showing the
sincere sense of support and community
that surrounds the hills with Peggy
spending much of the episode off doing
her own thing as Hank and Bobby go
through a whole emotional Arc this
episode of King of the Hill evades the
standard feelings of emptiness and lack
of direction that many finales suffer
from usually your pep talks go in one
ear and out the other but this time I'm
feeling the pap the charm of the two
sirloin would love conclusion is that it
feels just like any other episode but it
just so happens to knock it out of the
park by hitting on many of the show's
recurring themes though the early parts
of the episode feature some of the best
Hank and Bobby dialogue in the whole
series the concluding moments take it a
bit easier by allowing the animation to
do the talking scenes of the home
neighborhood coming out of their homes
one by one to enjoy a well-cooked meal
together tied together a show that even
in its roughest moments is about the
transformative power of loving your
neighbors for who they are the dynamic
between a conservative father and his
free-spirited son makes up much of the
central focus of King of the Hill so it
might not be a huge surprise that the
finale takes their relationship as its
Central Focus over the course of the
series Hank and Bobby have their bond
challenged in many ways but even without
outside instability pushing things to a
head there is the simple problem that
the two just don't have much in common
while the show often sees them making
peace with their differences to Sirloin
with love provides a heartwarming Twist
by finally giving them a shared interest
when Peggy announces that she'll be off
with friends for the night Hank is
concerned noting that he and Bobby don't
have all that much they can talk about
without her around however they
connected a restaurant when Bobby
correctly identifies a flaw in the stake
on his plate showing Hank that he is a
top-notch purveyor of meats everybody
knows the tiny bone side of the sirloin
is the most tender what kind of steak
joint is this a man at a nearby table of
Greece introducing himself as the coach
of the Heimlich County junior college
meet examination team which he asks
Bobby to join when Bobby asks for his
dad's approval Hank is so overwhelmed
with joy that he immediately agrees just
like that Bobby's on the team and Hank
has never been happier
keeping in step with the core format of
King of the Hill Bobby soon experiences
doubts about the team his father is so
Overjoyed to see him become a part of
though Bobby immediately proves himself
a skilled Grader by noticing a detail in
a cow carcass that his teammates don't
immediately see he clocks them as being
a little weird right off the bat when
they go out the night before they're
meant to compete they tell Bobby he
can't jinx them by eating meat before
the event after that they throw red
pepper flakes in the faces of their
competitors shocking Bobby however his
coach encourages this Behavior making
Bobby question his future with the group
did you know that no one can hear you
scream from inside a meat locker when
Bobby makes a simple mistake and the
others deride and ostracize him he tells
Hank he has to quit the team this causes
Hank to have somewhat of an overreaction
as he was so excited to finally bond
with his son this isn't so much about
the competition as it is about their
relationship a point that's driven home
when Bobby sees the grill his dad has
bought for him in celebration Peggy
tells him in no uncertain terms that
Hank's disappointment comes from the
happiness he felt when he realized that
he could finally share an important part
of his life with Bobby even though
Hank's feelings of sadness around
Bobby's desire to quit the meat
examination team are Justified Bobby has
every right to leave the strange group
the Shady tactics they resort to in
order to claim a win are only the tip of
the iceberg interactions with the others
show Bobby that there's something deeply
weird about every one of the people on
the team the focus on competition over
enjoyment unsettles him and plays a
major role in his decision to step away
it's clear that Bobby not only has a
good sense of Ethics but also a healthy
ability to keep his ego in check Hank's
pride in Bobby is adorable and a
stubbornness eventually wanes as he
realizes just how right Bobby was about
the team finally understanding his son's
desire to quit Hank learned a classic
King of the Hill lesson but to Sirloin
with love makes it easier on him than
usual he quickly realizes the error of
his ways and seeks to rectify his
mistakes although to Sirloin with love
is technically not the final episode of
King of the Hill more on that later it's
hard to imagine a more fitting end to
the series the story ends with Hank and
Bobby sharing a delightful moment as
they feed the neighborhood together even
though the two don't always see eye to
eye their shared love of grilling can
always bring them back together oh
you're just getting started Bobby you'll
be grilling your whole life just like
you
yep yep despite Hank's consistent series
defining declaration that boy ain't
right Bobby is arguably the most right
person in King of the Hill and he proves
it in the finale not only does he show
surprising maturity in pleading his case
with the wait staff when he realizes his
stake isn't what it should be but he's
also a great team member who's capable
of working with the goals of a larger
group in mind Bobby's calm and friendly
demeanor doesn't seem as special as it
is until we see it contrasted with
people who have such a long way to go in
their own development if Bobby's Ark had
to come to a close this was the time and
place for it to happen though he was
always capable of being profound Beyond
his years here he's able to forgive and
connect with his dad even when Hank is
being a bit immature besides that he
puts aside his own feelings of
resentment toward the team that treated
him badly stepping in where he's needed
so that they're able to succeed in the
competition even though he know longer
wants anything to do with it juggling
his father's expectations the need for
personal boundaries and his own
self-interest successfully is the kind
of thing that has us taking notes on how
to be more like Bobby Hill
a consistent truth in King of the Hill
is that you should keep things honest no
matter how much you want to win that
message comes back in a big way into
sirloin with love Bobby notices the
Shady dynamics of the meat examination
team early on and he finds himself
completely unwilling to engage in their
over-the-top attempts to hurt their
competitors though we know by now that
Bobby is a good kid who will follow his
own ethics above any group dynamics his
intuition has been honed into something
truly impressive by the serious
conclusion this episode is far from the
only competition gone wrong to appear on
King of the Hill but it is one of the
most revealing for its characters the
added stress on Bobby to do well with
the team so his father will continue to
be proud of him is Extreme but even
despite Hank's disappointment there's no
question that he truly loves his son
earlier in the episode when bobby gets
upset with himself for only getting
fourth place Hank is Overjoyed
celebrating his fourth place slot with a
level of enthusiasm that can't help but
be endearing the knowledge that Hank
doesn't care whether Bobby succeeds only
that they have a common interest only
pushes forward the enduring message of
fair play that pops up so often
throughout the series among Hank Hill's
beer drinking buddies Boomhauer is
always the most mysterious one with a
slurred rapid-fire way of talking making
it nearly impossible to understand him
and it just it ain't complicated you
know man knock it down Rubik's Cube man
you like tomato blue red man then you
get to one side and then mess it up the
other side man initially being pretty
one-dimensional boom hour is often
defined by his interest in women and
muscle cars though his luck with both is
regularly called into question when the
series starts unpacking the details of
his life regardless boom hour is highly
astute and capable of giving calm and
reasonable advice to others making him a
helpful guy to have around by the end of
the series Boomhauer gets a few
Spotlight episodes and even some fairly
profound moments with characters like
Bobby and Hank after spinning the whole
series Without ever actually stating
what his job is the last episodes tell
us that Hank's bestie Boomhauer was
actually a Texas Ranger the whole time
the Revelation occurs in a casual scene
in which Boomhauer smells the grill
outdoors and leaves his home to join in
his wallet pops open revealing a badge
and solving one of the show's big
mysteries in a perfectly low-key way
does this mean that Boomhauer was
casually spying on anti-government
conspiracy theorists Dale throughout
their friendship we may never know
to Sirloin with love acts as the finale
to King of the Hill but it wasn't the
last episode to actually air four more
episodes that had already been produced
premiered in syndication after the fact
The Honeymooners Bill gathers Moss when
Joseph met Laurie and made out with her
in the janitors closets and just another
manic Conde these are more like ordinary
episodes than series finales but that
doesn't mean they aren't still fun to
watch Hank's mother announces her
intention to marry a Man Hank hasn't
even met Bill decides to combat his
depression by getting some roommates in
Joseph's love life picks up steam in
just another maniconde the last episode
to air chronologically the often
combative relationship between Hank and
his neighbor Khan gains a new dimension
as the two spend some one-on-one time
with each other with man and Connie on a
trip Hank is tasked with checking in on
his neighbor deciding that medication is
unnecessary Hank tells Khan to not
bother waiting in line at the pharmacy
yeah you're right I think I'll
self-medicate with 50 000 BTUs of ass
kicking Hellfire this sends Khan into a
manic episode in which he becomes
uncharacteristically upbeat and wants to
work endlessly on a shared Grill project
with Hank however Hank soon realizes he
misunderstood the extent of Khan's
bipolar disorder when his neighbor hits
a low point and is unable to complete
the project though Hank doesn't always
behave in the best way he and Khan
ultimately end up becoming closer due to
their Newfound understanding to all good
things there must be an end even though
King of the Hill has an excellent
conclusion it can still feel bittersweet
to fans who wanted another 13 Seasons if
that's you you may be in luck as there
have been recent rumors of a Revival
series coming from original co-creators
Mike Judge and Greg Daniels though very
little information has been released to
date around what we could expect from a
return to Arlen chances are it would
involve quite a lot of talk of propane
and propane accessories and we wouldn't
want it any other way in January of 2022
Daniels told collider that his and
judge's idea for a Revival would start
with a time Jump aging the show's
characters significantly however it's
still unclear whether or not the Revival
will actually happen in September of
2022 it was announced that fox was
uninterested in bringing the series back
leaving judge Ann Daniels without a
definite home for the reboot King of the
Hill could still be coming back however
and judge and Daniels seem excited to
bring it to life spending years with the
hills was a formative experience for a
lot of sitcom fans so here's hoping the
new series will be every bit the low-key
Slice of Life we've come to know and
love
thank you